antenne 2 révèle le milliardaire akram
ojjeh décident d'installer le france à
beyrouth début 79 le président giscard
d'estaing rapproche la course du
continent avions et bateaux plus
nombreux et moins chère aide accrue aux
agriculteurs et aux artisans jacques
chirac intervient pour critiquer le
gouvernement
il attaque la politique africaine et la
doctrine sur le désarmement la politique
étrangère devant les députés
mitterrand marché debré couve de
murville face au ministre de virage là
messieurs bonsoir avant toute chose donc
cette information quand n 2 est en
mesure de vous révéler b maintenant bien
qu'elle ne soit rendue publique que dans
48 heures on sait enfin où va dormir le
france ce sera à beyrouth et c'est son
nouveau propriétaire akram auger l'homme
d'affaires saoudien qui viennent le
décidé il ya quelques heures le france
fera peau neuve dans six mois environ
pour son dernier voyage ce sera tout à
la fois à l'hôtel de luxe et un centre
culturel 15 cents chambres en tout c'est
à dire plus qu'à l'heure actuelle
alors pourquoi ce choix de beyrouth il
est prouvé s'il en est et bien pour
qu'ils puissent se représenter la france
a dit akram ojjeh qu'ils puissent
reporter la france à une époque où elle
participe aux efforts de paix en afrique
et au libre akram auger qui sera
l'invitée d'un de nos prochains cartes
sur table donc le france à beyrouth au
début de l'année prochaine
c'est officiel c'est définitif au
tableau d'honneur d'antenne 2 maintenant
un petit garçon de 8 ans emmanuel sans
lui ses deux petites soeurs muriel six
ans elisabeth sept ans serait morte
brûlée vive dans leur appartement de
verdun je vais vous laisser entendre
emmanuel qui va nous raconter toute son
histoire et dans quelques heures donc
après quelques heures de repos
il va parler avec vous le verrez
beaucoup de sang-froid et
beaucoup de courage de ce sauvetage
miraculeux
emmanuel 80
enfin après j'ai renversé un peu
d'essence et mon frère a vous d une
cigarette et fin prêt il y avait des
grandes flammes à ce moment là je suis
au fond alors qu'est ce que tu as fais
confiance à mes propos m
mais ce que tu avais peur à ce moment là
non j'avais peur pour ma soeur s'est
porté pour tes soeurs que tu avais peur
et qu'est ce que tu as ressenti que je
l'aimé bien parce que à un moment tu as
ressenti que que tu risquais aussi ta
vie ou maintenant des petites soeurs
sont à côté de toi
elles sont sauvées
voilà la politique maintenant avec une
rentrée remarquée de jacques chirac
jacques chirac qui ce matin exprimé de
vives réserves à l'égard d'un certain
nombre d'initiatives du gouvernement et
du chef de l'état lui-même initiative
qui a été dit ne sont pas conformes à la
place de la france dans le monde et de
l'homme dans la société
le prion du rpr sur les prix au plan
français de désarmement et surtout à la
politique africaine de la france
non mais écoutez donc jacques chirac le
friant du rpr dans une conférence de
presse ce matin
est il besoin de souligner le caractère
de rin erreur vous avez compris qu'il
s'agissait donc de luigi ringot je crois
que nous avons quelques petits problèmes
techniques en régie en ce moment luigi
ringot qui s'exprimait sur la politique
africaine également de la france je
pense qu'après un petit coup téléphone
je serai en mesure de vous dire qu'ils
nous allons entendre de jacques chirac
ou de dire un gros voilà donc nous
allons entendre comme prévu jacques
chirac le président du rpr qui je vous
le répète une fois de plus a sévèrement
critiqué la politique africaine de
l'elysée ce matin à l'occasion d'une
conférence de presse
jack est du mal à partir mais qui va
bien finir par arriver comme la premier
en tout cas la france devrait se garder
de lancer des idées qu'ils ne soient pas
susceptibles d'être mises en oeuvre on
l'a vu pour le nord sud on l'a vu un peu
pour le désarmement on risque de le voir
à nouveau sur le plan africain
la deuxième observation c'est que une
cette procédure à son rôle en atlantique
très affirmé cette espèce de
concertation ressemble fort à celle que
pourrait avoir le tan et nous apparaît
donc une orientation qui est également
préoccupante de même qu'elle dénote une
espèce de désir de voir les américains
prendre position en afrique et de se
mettre un peu à l'abri des américains en
afrique et nous pensons que les
américains n'ont rien à faire en afrique
pas plus d'ailleurs que les soviétiques
nous souhaitons ardemment et c'est ce
qu'avait indiqué le président de la
république il y à quelques temps que
l'afrique soit maintenue en dehors de la
rivalité des blocs
ce n'est pas parce que ces initiatives
soviétique
se développe qu'il faut obligatoirement
y répondre en sollicitant en suggérant
ont tous en une initiative américaine
j'ajoute que cela n'a pour résultat
actuellement me semble-t-il que de
détériorer les relations entre paris et
moscou et je ne vois pas très bien les
avantages que quiconque peut en retirer
et la 3ème observation c'est que ce
processus c'est un processus dangereux
qui va exactement à l'encontre de l'idée
que l'afrique doit être aux africains et
en dehors de la querelle des blocs et
qui à la limite pourrait provoquer une
vietnamisation de l'afrique
jacques chirac a ajouté que l'ambition
de son parti était de servir un grand
dessein pour la france le maire de paris
a également critiqué mais plus
légèrement la politique économique et
sociale du gouvernement ce qui lui a
valu le courroux de jacques blanc le sap
est à général du parti républicain qui
sans citer nommément jacques chirac a
reproché à certains de se laisser
prendre au jeu de l'opposition
pour sa part le premier ministre disait
ce matin sur france inter que le
programme de bois serait poursuivie avec
détermination mais qu'il comprenait
l'inquiétude des français quant à la
hausse des indices
ces réserves du rpr sur la politique
africaine du gouvernement on allait
retrouver quelques heures plus tard à
l'assemblée dans la bouche de maurice
couve de murville et plus encore dans
celle de françois mitterrand et de
georges marchais qui eux n'ont pas
ménagé leurs critiques
c'était en effet une après-midi de
politique étrangère à l'assemblée débat
sans vote ouverts par le ministre louise
berlingot qui est d'abord revenu sur la
formule l'afrique aux africains qui les
définit davantage comme un objectif que
comme l'affirmation d'années d'absence
monsieur de dire n est il besoin de
souligner le caractère dérisoire de
certains procès d'intention qui nous ont
été faits lors de l'action que nous
avons tout récemment menée au profit des
ressortissants français et européens de
kolwezi les motifs strictement
humanitaires qui nous inspirait nom
était hélas que trop justifié en
pratiquant la paix de manière active et
désintéressé la politique de solidarité
que je viens d'évoquer la france n'a
nullement
l'intention d'exercer un quelconque rôle
de gendarme de l'afrique dans l'action a
conduit en matière de sécurité comme l'a
appelé le présent d'un public lors de la
conférence franco africaine de paris
l'initiative doit être prise par les
états africains
c'est bien là le sens de l'effort
entrepris actuellement pas plusieurs
états africains pour venir en aide au
zaïre au moment où le gouvernement
conçoit de légitimes inquiétudes sur le
sort des étrangers venus d'europe qui se
trouve à kolwezi et aux chats bas à ce
moment là le gouvernement annonce c'est
une itération public aussitôt su au
zaïre annonce qu'il se range du côté du
président mobutu qu'il soutient ses
efforts ceux de son gouvernement et de
sa propre personne il viendra le cas
échéant pour s'opposer aux actions de
pénétration hochabaeff qu'ils y aillent
en adversaire déterminé de ceux qui se
sont révoltés dans cette province qui
tiennent kolwezi et qui tiennent de ce
fait dans leurs mains les ressortissants
étrangers
c'est un conseil des ministres qui a
posé le problème dans ces termes je
viens de vous le dire
confirmée quelques heures plus tard par
monsieur le porte parole de l'elysée
monsieur rentes ajoutant je le cite il
ne semble pas que des français étaient
est concerné par les actions menées à
kolwezi et qui ont abouti au mollet
stage de quelques européens
nous sommes opposés à toute ingérence
tous qu'elle vienne dans les affaires de
quelques peuples que ce soit sur tous
les continents et en toutes
circonstances nous sommes à fortiori
opposés à toute intervention militaire
fut-elle pas tease
et assistance ou coopération dès lors
qu'elle n'aurait pas pour objet d'aider
à son appel un pays a riposté à une
agression étrangère
c'est précisément pourquoi nous
dénonçons avec la plus grande vigueur la
politique que vous conduisez en afrique
votre engagement en afrique s'inscrit au
coeur de la politique de redéploiement
multinationales du grand capital
français celui-ci s'obstine à considérer
le combinant africain avec ses richesses
en matières premières
sa force de travail son espace
ces marchés comme une source essentielle
de profit ajoute que le ministre de la
coopération robert galère fait le point
sur la situation au tchad en annonçant
que les pertes français s'élevait à cinq
morts trois militaires deux coopérants
plus trois coopérants militaires
disparus
d'ailleurs je vous annonce d'ores et
déjà que demain nous diffuserons à notre
mort très intéressant sur le tchad et
sur les combats ces dernières semaines
mais revenons au débat proprement dit
est ce dossier afrique à travers lequel
se sont cristallisées les positions des
uns des autres
alors quels sont les enseignements que
vous tirez ce débat daniel bien deux
enseignements tout d'abord c'est que la
politique du président de la république
était défendu par monsieur guy ringot
n'a été approuvée que par l'udf et ce
par la voix de monsieur êtes un g mais
toutes les autres orateurs l'on
critiquait alors pour monsieur
mitterrand rue monsieur marché ça n'est
pas une surprise mais monsieur couve de
murville a été beaucoup plus mordant que
d'habitude et la deuxième remarque c'est
qu'après les propos très sévères de
monsieur de monsieur chirac tout à
l'heure et de monsieur couve de murville
eh bien on se demander dans les couloirs
si le rpr n'avait pas décidé de se
mettre très en retrait dans une sorte
d'opposition larvée au sein de la
majorité est en tous les cas cette
attitude de inattendu c'est résonance
inattendue d'un an tous
tout à fait différent de celui qui était
prévu à ce débat de politique étrangère
qui vous le savez ne sera pas sanctionné
par un vote
alors concrètement quelle est la
principale critique formulée début des
miens ce qui m'a le plus frappé c'est la
convergence des critiques de monsieur
couve de murville et de monsieur
mitterrand tous les deux
graignes que la france s'enlise dans une
politique dangereuse en afrique et
surtout d'autant plus dangereuse qu'elle
s'appuierait sur les états unis ce qui
risquerait de rallumer la guerre froide
avec l'urss tu viens tu ne sais pas à
qui daniel m'a donné sa voix mais en
tout cas elle en a perdu une partie la
pétale de rose poignée de riz ainsi a
débuté la deuxième journée du voyage du
chef de l'état encore cela s'est passé
d'abord à sartène où président a été
accueilli par le maire communiste
ensuite il y eut le petit village de
grosseto et enfin nouveau ajaccio et
celles à la préfecture que valéry
giscard d'estaing a présenté un plan
pour la corse avec comme grosses têtes
de chapitres la rénovation l'agriculture
l'amélioration de la desserte de l'île
et le lancement d'un journal télévisé
insulaire
nous rejoignons tout de suite nous
envoyés spéciaux en corse qui ont eu
quelques retards ou nous envoyer leurs
six mètres en pleine montagne du riz des
roses jeter pour le président c'est
l'accueil chaleureux des montagnards et
pour faire leurs pairs et pauvres
cartonnier et l'emploi précaire dans
cette cité de 6000 habitants
la corse n'est pas malade de la france
la corse veut être dans la france mais
elle veut tout autant être elle-même le
soleil acclamé par une foule nombreuse
le président se promener dans les duels
il a eu comme il le souhaitait son
premier vrai rendez-vous à des claques
la corse est belle la vie valéry giscard
d'estaing certaine il l'a répété dans le
village de grosseto et en fin de matinée
à lévis on a presque oublié le caractère
officiel de ce voyage la sécurité a
affirmé le chef de l'état et bien c'est
votre sympathie on a donc voulu profiter
de ces quelques heures passées ensemble
entre un président visiblement heureux
de mieux connaître les corps et une
population entière de cette première
visite un triple a dans leur ville et
marjo
les problèmes de transport de
communication avec le continent sont
parmi les plus importants de l'accord
c'est ce que nous ont dit les gens que
nous avons rencontrés bien le président
de la république on a longuement parlé
il a annoncé une augmentation de la
capacité des navires et une
modernisation de la flotte c'est ainsi
que dans les toutes prochaines années 5
nouveaux bateaux sont entrés en service
sur les lignes de corse pour les
liaisons aériennes de nouveaux appareils
plus modernes vont remplacer les
caravelles actuelle les horaires seront
aménagés et les tarifs seront harmonisés
avec ceux de l'ensemble du réseau
national
la protection des sites la corse a été
relativement protégé a dit le président
de la république mais il faudra être
vigilant et un programme d'aménagement
concerté du littoral va être étudiée
le plan de développement économique
c'était le parapher plus important le
chapitre le plus important son discours
le plan de développement économique de
1975 sera poursuivie s'y ajouteront des
mesures ponctuelles comme une prime
d'arrachage de la vigne qui viendra en
plus de celle déjà offerte par la
communauté européenne économique
on fera ce qu'il faut pour développer
l'artisanat avec un régime exceptionnel
des deux entreprises
et puis le développement des moyens de
formation et d'enseignement avec
notamment un lycée agricole qui était
attendue depuis longtemps en corse est
un institut régional d'administration ça
c'est la première fois qu'on en pas
création d'emplois l'état donnera
l'exemple en implantant dans l'île
certains de ses services
je ne ferai pas davantage en détail des
mesures annoncées le président a tenu à
dire aux corses qu en tant qu vergnas il
les admirais qui lui est même arrivé de
les jalouser il prend acte de la réalité
et de la sensibilité corse qui sont at
il étonné permanent de la diversité
française dans les années qui viennent
la corse va se trouver au centre d'un
monde méditerranéen qui agiteront bien
des remous eh bien quoi qu'il arrive la
république sera fidèle à la corse
accompli le président la délivrance est
président de la république
je prends acte de la réalité et de la
sensibilité corse qui sont des données
permanentes de la diversité française
telle qu'elle existe au sein de notre
république
mais mesdames et messieurs n'oubliez pas
non plus que la france a besoin de la
corse dans les années qui viennent la
corse va être au centre d'un monde
méditerranéen qu'agitent bien des remous
en face l'italie
notre soeur latine
connell angoisses et l'assaut de la
violence au sud l'afrique continent
pacifique et fraternelle est déchirée
par les tensions planétaire et doit
consolider l'indépendance de ces jeunes
est à en face de ces problèmes et de ses
risques
la france la chance de la france est de
rester unie sûre d'elle-même et de ses
institutions
fidèle à ses traditions son origine et
sa culture
elle n'a pas trop de tous ses fils et de
tous ses moyens pour tenir sa place dans
le monde et la france dont je suis le
président de la république
n'est-elle pas exactement celle que nous
a laissé l'empereur corse complété sous
le second empire par nice et la savoie
c'est bien le sentiment que vous avez
exprimées messieurs les présidents et
comme en irait-il différemment sur cette
terre de longues histoires et de
fidélité
mais soyez assurés que la république
elle aussi sera fidèle à la corse
en marge de ce voyage ajoute que les 24
autonomistes arrêté il ya quelques jours
ont tous été inculpé aujourd'hui quatre
d'entre eux ont eu des lycées en liberté
ajoute aussi un attentat encore assez
mystérieux la nuit dernière contre un
véhicule de la gendarmerie
un gendarme mobile a été grièvement
blessé par une arme à feu il s'agit de
la sécurité de tous et non pas de long
de séquelles folklore absurde a dit le
préfet de la haute corse
il faut que cela cesse pour tous et avec
tous enfin la voiture du colonel erulin
le commandant du 2e rep revenu depuis
hier à calvi a été détruite par une
bombe
une nouvelle élection annulée par le
conseil constitutionnel celle de la
communiste marie thérèse guthmann dans
la seine saint denis un nouveau
directeur pour l'insee pierre fauchon
nous n'avons tracer le portrait à 18h40
remplace donc en risque d'un goy à la
tête de l'institut national pour la
consommation et puis la rubrique social
maintenant avec les trois gros conflit
du moment manufrance ça vienne est
d'abord une action à 9 semaines après le
début des grèves
la situation est revenu à son point de
départ
après la réouverture de flins les
ouvriers des presses ont recommencé à
occuper leurs ateliers et des débrayages
ont ralenti la production
les mêmes causes produisant les mêmes
effets les chaînes de fabrication des
r18 vont être rapidement à cours décoté
de qu'est ce que produit l'atelier des
grandes presse à cléon l'occupation
continue malgré les divergences des
syndicats et des débrayages ont eu lieu
dans la matinée à sandouville
la situation est calme par contre à
billancourt et oman la direction de ce
conte et maintient sa position pas de
reprise des négociations tant qu'il
y'aura occupation ce conflit a été
évoquée ce matin par le premier ministre
il faut quand même accepté pour une fois
dans ce pays que les dirigeants des
entreprises fustal des entreprises
nationales ont des responsabilités ont
la possibilité d exercer ce n'est pas le
premier ministre le ministre de
l'économie ou le ministre de l'industrie
qui sont assis dans le bureau du
directeur du président au directeur
général des usines renault de zine
bernier de vénissieux qui dépendent
renault les charismes en grève le 30 mai
ont décidé hier soir d'occuper un
atelier cette grève qui concerne 250
salariés a entraîné le lock out
plusieurs ateliers de 5 à 6000
travailleurs sont touchés par cette
mesure
à l'origine cette grève l'installation
de contrôle au gras qui enregistrent les
distances parcourues
enfin les chariots l'instrument qualifié
de mouchard par les syndicats
le pdg de manufrance monsieur françois
hagan oakley a présenté son plan de
redressement cet après midi au conseil
d'administration
sur les 3000 salariés 334 seront
licenciés et 3 magasins sur les 53 que
compte la société seront fermés le pdg
de manufrance a confirmé que 20 millions
de francs seront demandés aux fonds de
développement économique et social sous
forme de prêts à long terme et que 20
autres millions doivent être trouvées
pour les neuf mois à venir
c'est demain que s'achève à paris le
salon de la machine à outils machines
outils tout simplement depuis des années
c'est l'un des secteurs les plus moroses
de l'industrie française à crise des
problèmes de trésorerie avait abouti à
un vieillissement du matériel et la
machine-outil 21 mille salariés en tout
était menacée d'écrasement par la
concurrence étrangère essentiellement
allemandes mais les professionnels
réunis porte de versailles commence à
voir le bout du tunnel
l'outil c'est à l'origine le
prolongement de la main humaine ainsi
fonctionne les machines outils les plus
simples comme par exemple un post
assouté mais cela peut être beaucoup
plus fabrication par usinage des
formations traitement électrique ou
chimique manutention aussi et bien
d'autres gestes pour la plupart
impossible à accomplir un la main tout
cela c'est le rôle de la machine outil
il est à peine besoin d'ajouter que ce
secteur est une clé il n'y a pas
d'industrie possible sans machine petits
puisque c'est elle qui fabrique tout le
reste et la france jusqu'ici n'était pas
très bien placé dans ce précieux secteur
les machines évolue sans cesse du fer à
souder d'autrefois à ce robot
entièrement programmée il ya bien des
états les fabricants français n'ont pas
toujours été aussi rapides et inventif
que leurs concurrents notamment les
américains et les allemands
enfin et surtout la crise des
investissements a frappé ici directement
faute d'argent et aussi il faute de
confiance en l'avenir
les industriels français pendant des
années ont acheté moins de machines et
laisser vieillir celle qu'ils avons
résultats l'an dernier la machine-outil
française touché le fond soixante quinze
mille tonnes vendues en 77 contre près
du double en 71
dans ce secteur la france était tout
simplement en train de quitter le groupe
des grands pays industriels aujourd'hui
la pente
comment ça remonte
il faut pas dire que les choses vont
mieux il faut dire que nous est d'abord
elles ne vont pas plus mal depuis
quelques mois le a lancé cette descente
pour nous stabiliser
dans notre industrie qui est une
industrie dans lequel le cycle de
fabrication est très long les tendances
sont longues à s'inverser mais nous
pouvons penser avec les chiffres que
nous avons enregistré depuis quelques
mois cela ira mieux
même si nous n'avons pas encore
enregistré toutes les conséquences de
l'acte et il est certain que la liberté
des prix qui va permettre un certain
nombre de nos clients de reconstituer
des marges d'autofinancement ne peut
être que favorable à une profession
comme la nôtre yelle jouer la liberté
des prix et un an et n'a pas abusé
puisque depuis le début du mois de
janvier 77 là osé pris la mesure du
français vers 7 %
la machine outils de demain en voici une
sepur mans est simplement un robot
économiquement son avenir un meilleur
viens de l'entendre les restes l'emploi
il n'y a plus personne pour tenir le
pinceau et ce serpent un peu inquiétant
signifie plusieurs os en moins en
revanche il faut beaucoup de monde et
d'une qualification élevé pour le
concevoir et le mettre en oeuvre
alors la bonne santé du secteur
machines-outils ne changera sans doute
pas grand chose aux données arithmétique
de l'emploi mais l'a tout de même un
effet favorable elle exerce une pression
vers le haut sur la qualification des
emplois à l'étranger soutien de la chine
la création d'une force interafricaine
ses 106 hopping lui-même qui l'a annoncé
dans un discours si violemment anti
soviétique que les représentants de
l'urss et du pays de l'est ont quitté la
salle le premier ministre libyen à paris
le commandant jalloud d' est en france
pour quelques jours violents combats
entre sahraouis et marocains il y aurait
plusieurs morts et le polisario annonce
que l'aviation française appuierait les
troupes maroc en france cette fois-ci
double élection à l'académie française
edgar faure et michel déon est élu tous
deux au premier tour l'ancien priant
l'assemblée nationale succède à andré
françois poncet malgré la tentative de
jean-edern hallier qui a tout de même
obtenu 7 voix cette voix de dix mortels
et michel déon occupera lui le fauteuil
de jans la plus belle carte de visite
des hommes politiques français edgar
faure 69 ans treize fois ministre deux
fois président du conseil sous la
quatrième république
président de l'assemblée nationale
pendant cinq ans jusqu'en avril dernier
champion incontesté de l'improvisation
edgar faure est aussi romancier sans
ambition essayiste politique avec brio
historien de qualité son dernier ouvrage
la banqueroute de law n'est pas pour
rien dans son succès d'aujourd'hui
si on oublie un peu les romans policiers
par lui publié sous le pseudonyme d'
edgar sendets
michel déon 59 ans l'écrivain le plus
discret qui soit évite autant que
possible de vivre à paris préférant le
rivage grec ou irlandais le plus
brillants représentants de la droite
littéraire française ce qui fait de lui
un écrivain hors de son temps est un
auteur à succès avec les poneys sauvages
un taxi mauve le jeune homme vert et les
20 ans du jeune homme vers son oeuvre
nostalgique et maurrassienne fait de lui
un maître du roman romanesque servi par
une plume élégante et désinvolte michel
déon est aussi historien dramaturge
essayiste et pamphlétaire or maintenant
un record qui promet jacky ickx a battu
sur sa porsche le record absolu du tour
au cours de la première séance d'essais
des 24 heures du mans 100 minutes cinq
minutes ou jusqu'à ce qu'il aura fallu à
hagenbach cet après midi à roland garros
pour venir à bout du mexique et un
ramirez trois manches 6 3 6 3 6 0
un bogue dans toute sa plénitude d'un
ramirez assez désabusé
quant à l'autre quart de finale il
opposait l'américain dips à l'italien
bras d'outils qui a gagné assez
facilement en trois sets
orion bornes première s ce ne fut ni un
match ni même une démonstration ramirez
s'étaient déjà battus quand il est entré
sur le court alors il a fait le clown
board dans ces conditions n'a pas eu à
forcer son talent ce fut une promenade
de santé
à peine un match d'échauffement alors
dans ces conditions il ya quand même une
question que tous encore battre borg à
la régulière et dans un grand tournoi il
frigorifique d'entrée le moral de ses
adversaires d'ailleurs son surnom c'est
iceborg jeu de mots facile autour
d'icebergs raul ramirez s'étaient
pourtant prévenu déclarait d'ailleurs
mardi soir après qu'on lui ait annoncé
qu'il rencontrerait le suédois en quart
de finale
je n'ai jamais eu de complexe devant lui
il est fort certes mais j'ai ma petite
idée pour le perturber
apparemment le mexicain n'a rien trouvé
de mieux que les pitreries qui
malheureusement n'ont pas déridé borg un
seul instant le tennis n'a certainement
pas été le vainqueur de cette partie
mais peut-on reprocher à borg
l'écrasante domination qui devient
impressionnant pour les comics longueur
il y avait un tiercé à evry et aussi la
combinaison gagnante cette le 6 et le 12
vous voyez les rapports s'inscrire sur
votre écran un peu moins de 3000 francs
dans l'ordre pour 5 francs voilà la
météo maintenant un temps mi figue mi
raisin pour la saint médard aujourd'hui
sur la moitié nord du pays temps couvert
et passagèrement pluvieux sur la moitié
sud un ciel variable et s'il faut en
croire le dicton s'il pleut à la saint
médard il pleuvra ensuite 40 jours sauf
si saint barnabé dans trois jours il
vient couper le nez à saint-médard
attendant donc samedi demain et bien
brumes et nuages sur tout le pays avec
des pluies au nord de la loire et des
orages sur les régions méditer les dires
méridionale j'y suis arrivé voilà vents
forts près de la mairie de la
méditerranée et peu de changements ce
qui concerne les températures
23h20 le dernier journal vous sera
présentée par bernard rapp
je vous souhaite une excellente fin de
soirée jeudi prix nous excuser pour les
incidents techniques qui ont perturbé le
cours normal de ce journal mais je vous
retrouve demain avec plaisir bonsoir à
tous